question that was just asked what are
your top three favorite openings please
I don't really have too much of a
favorite opening a favorite chest piece
or anything like that the classical
openings are probably my favorites like
uh Duru Lopez or or uh the Sicilian
because there there are so many
different dynamical posal kind of
possibilities and uh learning them at an
early age teaches you to play a whole
lot of different
uh different positions uh and one thing
that I was taught at at an early age uh
was that I should play many different
openings just to you know broaden my my
horizons I think that's that's helped me
become more of a universal uh veral
player without any you know great
preferences because I think that's
something that will uh slow you down and
hinder you again